today we're going to look at some
questions from the um
relationships forum on reddit lots of
confused and helpless people go on to
this forum looking for advice on their
relationships i may not be an expert
on on marriage or on relationships but i
am at least an expert compared to the
sort of
hapless saps who go looking for advice
on reddit that's
that's generally one of the good things
about living in a collapsing
civilization
is that everyone is so stupid and crazy
that i look pretty good by comparison so
it's good for my self-esteem anyway
so let's go through a few of these i
think these are some recent questions
that were posed
all the advice given by the redditors is
not good let me give you the
the uh the truth of it so here we go
this is
headline i cheated on my partner and i
don't know what to do
it's a 24 year old female cheating with
a 25 year old male
she says last night i got incredibly
drunk with a friend 26 year old male
who i trusted and have been friends with
for years we are both in long-term
relationships
and have never expressed romantic
attraction towards each other because
for one
i never liked him like that well
apparently you did miss
apparently you did and for two we're
both in loving relationships
apparently not miss apparently not while
we were super drunk he asked me to dance
and of course i said yes because i'm the
type of person that loves to dance
it was not romantic dancing it was more
fun because we were listening to upbeat
music
then he kissed me and i didn't know what
to do i was both shocked and super drunk
and i don't really remember much of what
happened but i know
we didn't have sex or do anything sexual
besides kiss he might have groped me but
i don't know
i'm very stressed out with a nasty
hangover i already am going to be not
friends with the guy because i can't
believe he'd do that
especially when i was much more drunk
than him now what do i do about my
boyfriend we're moving in together this
month we already signed a one-year lease
and i love him to bits
this man wants to marry me and spend the
rest of his life with me where do i even
begin to tell him that i did such a
horrible thing i can't stomach thinking
about it i can't imagine telling him
any advice is appreciated okay first of
all
you've already got the excuses teed up
don't you how could he do this
how could he be the one who does this i
was much more drunk than he was
yeah well who's whose fault was it that
you decided to get drunk but did he hold
you down
like use a funnel and force uh miller
light down your throat
would he waterboard you no this is a
choice you made
and what were you doing hanging out one
on one at night
with a member of the opposite sex and
then getting drunk
and you're supposedly in a relationship
you care about so how was this plan
supposed to work what did you think was
gonna happen
literally no good can come of that no
good only bad
so you're doing something in a
relationship where you know that what
you're doing right now it can't help
your relationship
it can only hurt it's just a matter of
how much is it going to hurt
and you decided to do it anyway and this
is why people don't want to hear it but
the truth is if you're in a relationship
especially if you're getting married or
you are married you shouldn't be having
one-on-one hangout sessions
with friends of the opposite sex people
don't want to hear it but it's true take
it from a guy's been married for 10
years okay
if you do decide to do this anyway
though you especially shouldn't be
drinking
and dancing as well you're just asking
for trouble
and just another point here ladies
if a man is drinking with you or even if
he's not and he asks you to dance and
he's not like related to you
but it's just a quote friend it is 100
a sexual slash romantic thing every
single time 100 of the time
so here's what i would say you're not
responsible or mature enough
to be in a relationship right now this
is totally your fault
and it's also the guys while you both
share 100 of the blame so tell your
boyfriend
what you did if he leaves you you
deserve it
and just try not to get raging sloppy
drunk with some other dude
the next time you're in a relationship
so that's can you manage that
it's kind of a low bar but if you can
get over that bar i think you'll be fine
headline here is my boyfriend sucks at
gift giving
how do i approach him about it as the
title said my boyfriend sucks at gift
giving
honestly i don't care much about gifts
but sometimes i feel like
if he could just tell me he doesn't know
what to gift
me for christmas or birthday for example
i wouldn't be as bothered
writing here is not is not stellar
examples of his gifts
him and i was long distance for a while
him and i was long distance
him and i was long distance for they're
not sending their best to reddit they
really aren't
him and i was long distance for a while
because we were pursuing our education
at different states well you should have
pursued it
harder than you did ma'am we were
pursuing our education at different
states and he tell me so much about this
friendly
stray dog outside of his dorm i love
dogs and every time i go and visit him
he'd always take me to pet the dog so
for my birthday a few years ago he
decided to commission someone a portrait
of this stray dog
yes a dog i saw a pet maybe four times
whom i have no ownership
uh but i'm guessing since i was so eager
hearing about how cute it is means i
want a portrait of it
this this is a college student this is a
college educated person
this is what yes this this individual is
spending 90 000
on an education and she cannot even
write a sentence
he hyped it up as something i would
really love but when i saw his gift i
really tried my hardest to not look
disappointed
the amount he tipped the artist is the
same price of commission so like
i'd rather him spending that much money
on me it felt like my birthday money was
split with the artist and that's just
one example
i'd say about 80 of his gifts for me are
in the realm of
baby i appreciate the thought but why
did you think i need this
he's a very loving boyfriend don't get
me wrong but it sucks when i put a lot
of efforts into gift to giving
and have something i don't even use or
need in return
i'm not exaggerating i knew he liked
seals so for one of his birthdays i got
him to see and pet a seal in person
for another occasion i purchased a big
package from the world wildlife
federation for him to adopt a seal
and hand made him a seal plush and my
favorite gift from him is still the
scrap book he made me
though very clumsily made and not
organized i'd still value it over any
pricey arts he's commissioned that i
have no use
so it's not like i need something super
expensive
so reddit what do i do a side hire an
english tutor
how do i tell him that i don't really
like the majority of his gifts i'm
asking this because my birthday is in
april and he already hyped me up
about what i will get and i am just
scared of another disappointing gift
okay
oh my gosh a few problems here
first of all don't say you don't care
about gifts don't insult my intelligence
don't assault the intelligence of your
boyfriend don't say you don't care about
it you obviously care about gifts you
just you just rambled about it
for 46 pages you you care about gifts
all women do
i mean all people do most people do i
mean i don't really care
i actually don't care about gifts but
i'm like a sociopath so that's most
people who have regular human emotions
do care about them so that's the first
thing also i mean
i'm not going to say that i would want a
painting of a stray dog as a gift
but it was thoughtful and it was
expensive so you should be grateful for
that
and your gift was what you took him to
pet a seal
how humiliating how embarrassing must
that have been for him
who wants to pet a seal i guarantee you
he didn't want to do that
and you dragged him along to some like
seal petting zoo
and there's a bunch of four-year-olds
and your poor boyfriend
petting the seal like this is great babe
thanks so much for this
and also another thing a stuffed animal
seal once again i guarantee you no i i
mean i know masculinity is not what it
used to be in this culture but come on
i that that is not his favorite gift i
can tell you that right now so get your
own house in order
don't throw stones when you live in a
seal petting zoo
here's another one this is from a guy
this time
i've been dating my girlfriend as a 23
year old male i've been dating my
girlfriend 24 year old female for about
six months now
she's fairly active on instagram with a
couple accounts her main account is
about 2 000 followers
i'm not too into instagram don't post
often and have like 300 people on it
only following meme pages and friends
i've started to notice that whenever
she's feeling she or something bad
happens she posts scandalous pictures on
instagram
for example she recently found out that
she had to spend 200
on a dental issue that wasn't fully
covered by insurance right after she
posted a saucy picture
i mean who doesn't who doesn't react to
dental bills that way
i cannot tell you how many times i've
been at the dentist they give me the
bill
and i'm so frustrated i just strip all
my clothes off it you know we all have
been there before
it's a normal human reaction another
time we were in a sort of week-long
disagreement about something
and at the worst point she posted a sexy
pic
of herself in lingerie i know she's
really into her instagram and who
doesn't like
posting hot photos every now and then
what concerns me is that she uses it as
a coping mechanism to deal with
things happening in her life it doesn't
bother me too much right now but it
makes me worry about our potential
future if she's so quick to look for
social media validation
it feels like an unhealthy coping
mechanism but maybe i'm overthinking it
how can i help her deal with things
without relying on instagram or is this
not something to even worry about
okay so the options you're giving me
right now is how do i help her deal with
it
or should i not worry about it let me
give you option c okay go through door
number three
leave her dump her kick her ass to the
curb that's that's that's the option you
should be taking
she takes her clothes off as a coping
mechanism
do you hear yourself right now this is
your girlfriend
now let me ask you something how else
do you think this girl is coping what
other forms of
coping is she doing because i can tell
you right now
she is now or she soon will be
coping with the assistance of some guy
she met at the gym
okay she's going to meet some guy at the
gym and they're going to be doing a lot
of coping together a whole lot of coping
between the two
lots of feeling happening feeling of all
types
coping and copping feels so have some
self-respect
a woman who undresses for other men or
for the public
or for anyone is not worth your time
self-respect okay finally
the title here is my girlfriend is a
poopoo head please help
she meows like a cat randomly and cries
like a baby
when threatened she burrows into things
and makes dramatic fainting noises
what do i do she burrows into things
when threatened
is she a gerbil don't date gerbils
that would really be my advice it's
illegal in most states
and unadvisable in all states really so
i'd say time to let this one go
as well um you you've made it to mammals
yeah i'm trying to look at the silver
lining so that's good progress you're on
mammals but really you want to stick
with
the human species is what i would
that's that's i would recommend that um
i'm old-fashioned i'd admit but
with my advice there okay so i think i
just recommended to everyone that they
break up
that's been my advice and i admit look
if you aren't married
and you aren't even engaged i think
ultimately breaking up is usually the
best answer
to most of your serious problems because
it's probably heading that way anyway
and you're just dating so it doesn't
actually matter that much
and you could you could break up like
with a text message that's how unserious
it is
i don't recommend that but you could so
that's something to keep in mind
i mean don't do that but you can so just
break up